In May 2018,
the European Commission put forward
a proposal
for the next EU's long-term budget.
The proposal is a result
of open debate with citizens,
beneficiaries of EU funding,
Members of the European
and national Parliaments,
representatives of EU member states.
We have conducted
a rigorous examination of all policies
and proposed an ambitious but balanced
budget: one that is fair for all.
Investing more than ever in research,
innovation and the digital sector
means investing in Europe's future.
Our next programmes for research,
innovation and for digital projects,
will allow our Union
to bridge the current investment gap,
become a front-runner
in market-creating innovation
and capture
the real value of the data economy.
How will we do this?
By working together.
Because together we are stronger
and can achieve more!
The EU Regional and Cohesion policy
will keep reducing economic
and social disparities
between countries and regions.
It will be simpler and more flexible,
to be able to adapt easily to new
priorities and better protect citizens.
The budget for the youth programme
Erasmus+ will be doubled
to enable more young people
across Europe to study.
This would give them more opportunities.
Every euro that we invest in Erasmus
is an investment in our future.
With relatively modest amounts,
the EU budget will continue mobilizing
public and private investments
throughout Europe...
... supporting economic growth
and job creation.
The Investment Plan for Europe
has proven a success
when it comes to mobilizing
private investment and creating jobs.
With InvestEU,
we are taking this successful model
and expanding it across the many
EU financing programmes on offer.
We are simplifying,
doing more with less,
and placing a stronger focus
on social investments.
A modernised Common Agricultural
Policy that ensures safe quality food
and fairness
for the farmers who produce it.
This means support for sustainability,
environmental initiatives,
innovation in farming
and developing vibrant rural areas.
A greater share of the EU budget
than ever before
will be devoted to protect the
environment and fight climate change.
With an increase of funding
of almost 60% for LIFE programme,
the EU budget can contribute
to protecting our environment
and speeding up the transition
to a clean, energy-efficient,
low-carbon
and climate-resilient economy.
Investments in security and defence
will be significantly boosted
so that Europe can effectively respond
...and protect EU citizens,
their values and way of life.
No Member State can meet
these challenges on its own.
That is why the EU steps up its role
in security and defence.
The European Defence Fund
will support cross-border investments
in areas needed
to protect our citizens -
for example encrypted software
and drone technology.
The EU budget for border and migration
management will be almost tripled...
to make
the EU’s external borders stronger,
to make migration policy fairer
and more realistic,
and to improve internal security
More funding will be available
to promote peace and stability,
to defend the EU’s interests
in the world...
...and provide development assistance
and humanitarian aid,
with flexibility for a faster response
to new crises and challenges.
With the United Kingdom
leaving the Union,
there will be only 27 countries
contributing to the budget...
...while the EU citizens still want
a Europe that is prosperous
and sustainable, safe and secure,
stronger on the global scene.
The Commission proposes
a modern long-term budget,
aligned to its political priorities,
fit to deliver,
and focused on the EU added value.
A Europe, that takes greater
responsibility for its citizens,
needs resources
that match its ambitions.
The EU’s long-term budget,
proposed by the Commission,
can enter into force only when approved
by all of member states in the Council
and with the consent
of the European Parliament.
And time really matters:
- to allow for the new programmes
to start on 1 January 2021
- to give certainty to authorities,
partners and beneficiaries of EU funding
- to keep the momentum
of the economic recovery
and show that the EU
is united and ready to deliver.
A budget for a Union the Protects,
Empowers and Defends